welcome back to another gadget lab show
i am michael colori i'm christina
bonnington uh in a little bit alexandra
is going to show us a cool mouse and
keyboard but first christina is going to
bring us up to date on what's been going
on in the apple versus samsung trial yes
so last week apple and samsung went to
court in san jose california and they're
finally you know trying to close this
whole back and forth
patent lawsuit that's been going on for
over a year now so what's what's the
central issue like what is it that each
company what's what's the company's beef
right so there's actually a lot of
things going on here uh what started was
apple sued samsung for infringing on its
design patents for the iphone and the
ipad
and then uh they're also suing samsung
for infringing on some ui elements like
the bounce back feature when you reach
the end of a list in ios and it kind of
springs up
things like that and then samsung is
countersuing apple for infringing on its
3g related patents and so there's like a
whole bunch of these like moving parts
going on and the nine-member jury has to
make sense of it all and most of them
don't even have a tech background i saw
one of them falling asleep
when uh during samsung's opening
arguments last tuesday
uh well to me the the thing
in reading your reports that i really
liked was that um
a lot of execs are taking the stand and
higher level people and they're sort of
being forced to give up
things that they normally would never
talk about in public yeah so we got to
hear about the origin story of the
iphone and the ipad the ipad was started
being developed back in 2003 way before
the iphone and we've also gotten to see
some iphone and ipad prototypes
in real life they were passing them
around to the jury and stuff i wanted to
run up there and grab one but then i
thought they'd kick me out and that
wouldn't be good at all
gadget lab hands-on exclusive
so uh where does it stand now we're on a
short recess right oh right yeah so uh
they took a few days off and so right
now they're going through a whole bunch
of expert witnesses trying to
instruct the jury
sway their opinion one way or another
with these expert opinions and so it's
starting to get a little on the dry side
because you've got to go nitpicking into
all the details of these patents
okay who do you think is going to win
you know ah it's hard i think
i'm leaning towards apple a little bit
there their council is super polished
they tell a good story if you don't know
much about tech and you're just
listening to the lawyers talking you
feel like the apple lawyers are kind of
like
the good guys and the samsung lawyers
are a little more they have a little
more attack they're kind of more
defensive
and not quite as friendly sounding oh
well yeah it's the little things that
matter unfortunately yeah so but we'll
see it's totally up in the air okay well
you're gonna be back on site uh for the
for the meat of it not for every day but
for the big important days and you can
continue to read christina's awesome
coverage on wired.com gadget lab
so thanks for joining us thank you
alexandra's here hello i couldn't help
noticing these strange and unusual
computer peripherals you have sitting in
front of you they are very strange
what are they they are two new products
from microsoft they are basically this
is a mouse and it's called the wedge
bluetooth mouse that's groovy yeah it's
so small it's a tiny little thing and
it's basically supposed to be used with
a tablet so the the fat part sits in
your hand and then your fingers kind of
slope down towards the table yeah kind
of like that wow just move it around and
then here is the wedge keyboard
and right now it has a cover on it
and then you take the cover off and
ta-dah oh look at that
and then what do you do with the cover
you just throw it away
no
turn it into a stand
for
the tablet that's pretty cool
it is really cool actually and uh you
know it works with pretty much any
device i guess
um since it's bluetooth yeah which is
kind of cool so you don't you don't have
that old uh standard that they used to
use where you needed to take up a usb
port or anything like that right right
so it's totally wireless i mean you
don't need to have there's only like one
usb port on these windows 8 tablets
anyway so
there's like less clutter
and yeah very
compact nice now i've i've actually been
um i've actually been kind of interested
in
these portable keyboards for a while
because i've been testing them on
specifically on tablets and i was just
using this one before before we started
taping and it's uh it's very comfortable
it's really nice
it's even better than um i think better
than uh apple's bluetooth keyboard right
that is around the same size and around
the same weight although with the cover
this one's a little bit bulkier but but
the cover you know it is also a stand it
is also stand and is also
kind of useful for just like everyday
use so this the cover also doubles as
like the power on off switch for oh so
you put that on and it shuts off yeah
and then you can also put it on
the screen of a tablet and then hold it
out oh very cool you can carry it around
like a book or something so it has like
some friction to it and does this work
on any any gorilla glass or is there to
be particular material i don't think it
needs to be a particular material it's
just like any sort of
plastic or glass
surface it does have kind of a nice grip
to it yeah it's sort of effortless like
you don't really need to clamp onto it
with your hand you just kind of hold it
yeah um so i think this this sort of
thing probably takes on uh greater
significance than it should because like
microsoft has been making mice and
keyboards forever yeah like 30 years so
um but now that they're branching out to
hardware with their own tablet is this
sort of thing that's kind of drawing
more attention to them it's drawing a
lot of attention just because they're
really focused on hardware now and
with these two devices it kind of shows
that they care about even like the tiny
little things that are attached to
tablets so
and some more care into what they're
making
you know and it shows i mean like i have
that arc touch mouse the one that we
gave away a few like months ago um where
you click it and it turns on and then
you flatten it and it turns off sort of
like how you know this one has a
built-in on off device and that actually
won a bunch of awards and it's an
awesome mouse it's a great mouse you
know and people are kind of surprised to
pick it up and see the microsoft logo
and they're like i didn't know they made
mice yeah so now they're making other
cool things and they probably will for a
while yeah well we look forward to
seeing all the rest of them that you're
going to be bringing in over the next
few months
and just fyi this is eighty dollars and
this is seventy dollars okay a little
steep a little steep but
maybe worth the price for some people
yeah you know you always pay for design
uh well that's all we have time for this
week and we will be back next week on
the gouging lab and until then thank you